there was one thing they did deliver
today a message to Royal Mail boss Simon
Thompson
this Vision in pink outside Parliament
was a show of solidarity thousands of
postal workers across the country
beginning a new wave of strikes
demonstrating they're not backing down
yet
stayed for 12 years we're only asking to
be able to heat our homes to eat you
know to take our kids out for treats to
put fuel in our cars and it's just got
harder and harder
I've been working for Royal Mail for 28
years in Sheffield
kids aren't getting presents like what
we would normally buy them at Christmas
you know same with family members we've
had to cut back on that
and even socializing you know you can't
go out as much you know and socialize
with your friends and family you know
because you just got to watch every
penny
as well as posties there was the poster
boy himself
quite a bright red van but this was a
nod to the company's past as the union
fears for its future
my name is Paul Blair 20 years I think
Wilson Northwestern the terms and
conditions you know overtime schedule
they're doing away with all their
changing their times extra workload no
overtime so um you know it's a big fight
and I'll fight Worth Fighting For It
means that between now and Christmas
there is a conveyor belt of strikes five
more planned in the next two weeks with
millions of parcels already piling up
because of the disruption
we'll do everything we can to get
letters and parcels and Christmas cars
delivered in time for Christmas but to
give us a chance of doing that access
the network early please
like other disputes in this winter of
walkouts a resolution seems increasingly
distant the Prime Minister now not
ruling out extending new anti-strike
laws to limit the impact
thousands of soldiers have also had
Christmas leave canceled so they can
cover vital Services what I am going to
do is ensure that I minimize the
disruption to people's lives and make
sure that we protect lives and that's
what we're working on right now with
resilience and contingency plans but
also looking at tough new laws but the
cost of these strikes is both public and
personal the multiple walkouts
translating to thousands in lost wages
the more they strike the more money they
lose of course at a time when they can
least afford it one would have thought
that by now their resolve may have
started to waver but judging by this
it's stronger than ever
the union says they'll strike for as
long as it takes Christmas may be the
focal point but this disputes unlikely
to end there Arthur Bennett Sky News